even in this campaign there are still
discernible neutral in arguable facts I
realize that statement will now be run
past fact-checkers but in an opinion
flood of biblical proportions this is
what actually factually happened to the
presidential race after the debate as
this long week began wagering on the
Clinton Trump election at the
International online gambling site
Betfair calm was as the debate began
63.1% clinton 34.6% trump after the
debate ended wagering was 68.7% clinton
29.6% trump it has widened and narrowed
a few fractions of a point since but
that's what the debate did the swing
towards people betting on Clinton to win
and on Trump to lose move 10 points in
her favor this is the result not of
people trying to influence the election
nor people hoping for one outcome nor
people whose jobs depend on one outcome
nor people whose jobs depend on how well
they analyze politics nor even people
whose jobs it is to make the election
seem close in order to keep you watching
listening or reading that 10 percent
swing in odds in Hillary Clinton's favor
came from people who are putting their
money where their mouth is gamblers and
gamblers can't afford to waste time or
money trying to influence nor hope nor
analyze nor keep it close they just have
to assess what they see and be prepared
to lose actual cash money if they are
wrong and the bet fair numbers were not
an outlier
this is what wagering at predicted Ward
looked like as the debate began 64 38
Clinton after 66 34 Clinton a
seven-point swing it briefly bounced
two-point back towards Trump then went
further to 68 33 Clinton by Wednesday to
borrow a phrase from another political
time follow the money
it's like polling only with something to
counter the fact that the people in
polls lose nothing if they're wrong or
if they lie or if they don't know what
the hell they're talking about
the gamblers have skin in the game of
course so do others in a different way
and many of them are also gambling
maybe for bigger stakes still now my
overpaid friends in the media Sean
Hannity said in defensive trump on fixed
news on Tuesday well they have their
chauffeured limousine they like their
fine shake houses and expensive wine
lifestyles Oh Sean you don't have any
friends that marvelous soundbite has
been unpacked everywhere Hannity has
chauffeured to work by a driver used to
read commercials from one of his radio
sponsors a steakhouse flies by a private
jet has a net worth of at least twenty
nine million dollars fine steak houses
yes doctor that's the patient over there
but Sean Hannity is one of those media
types who has bet the farm in his case a
very very very very large farm on Donald
Trump Hannity has not bet the farm the
way Bill O'Reilly has tentatively
leaving himself just enough of a climb
down in case Trump self-destructs before
or as a result of the election even
though Trump might be the closest thing
Bill has to a friend Hannity has not bet
the farm the way the putrid Joe
Scarborough has spending months praising
Trump and trying to normalize his
candidacy accepting Trump's thanks for
being a supporter the day after the New
Hampshire primary and confessing at a
public event last November that he had
advised Trump I'm actually called on
booked and said Donald listen you need
to speak in complete sentences at
debates after your second debate I
walked into his office I said Donald do
you know how I read I said usually ready
before a debate and then after months of
rumors I heard the last Christmas
Joey scars was not chosen to be Trump's
vice president by now Joey scars had
grown afraid he might become a modern
Franz von poppin the guy who just knew
he could control and infamous German
political candidate so Joe had thrown
into reverse so quickly the engine flew
right out of the car and guess what if
Trump wins sorry Joey scars you will
still be the franz von poppin of the
21st century but no Hannity has no such
climbed down it's understandable save
for the big live events like town halls
and debates the ratings for cable news
the shows like Hana DS are all flat
compared to 2012 and disastrous compared
to 2008 after the last election Hannity
was demoted down the Fox News chain he
might be out soon anyway he's desperate
he might as well bet on the longshot and
that's what he's doing ten years ago I
used to co-host one hour of Dan
Patrick's radio show every day and at
least once a week in the studio next to
me preparing to do his show as I
finished up my show with Sean Hannity
nicest guy in the world
we had several conversations they all
went like this please thanks for putting
me on the worst persons list last night
he would say every time you do that I
get 10,000 more viewers I love it they
won't let me mention your name on my
show or I'd return the favor he meant it
I don't know why everybody thinks we
hate each other
it's just television it's just
entertainment just trying to make a
living just like you one day he had me
in his radio studio with him as he
started his radio show he referenced me
on the air not my name all positive and
collegial and friendly and I left
shaking at the mercenary a morality I
had just witnessed so Hannity is
gambling just like the people at Betfair
and predict it only the ones that bet
fair and predicted aren't desperate
they're professionals
that's the closer I'm Keith Olbermann
watch this space